a man died after eating a bag of black
licorice every day
so I'm getting older and I like black
are you forever admitting that [__] that
means you're old I like what happened in
your mouth it's like you know like
someone has like a stroke and then they
can speak Italian that's sort of what
happened with like black licorice for me
in January 2019 he collapsed out of
McDonald's and died well okay first of
all he's at a McDonald's not driving
through inside there walked in yeah so I
think we got there's a window into his
life he had just dropped his tribe in
the garbage and was going back a second
you want the usual like that's how much
McDonald's knows this guy the man in
Massachusetts had a poor diet and smoked
a pack of cigarettes a day oh they also
studied his medical history which
included heroin use checking for black
licorice but it was a switch from red to
black licorice three weeks before his
death the doctor said prove fatal we're
always blaming black stuff they are I
like the idea that the New England
Journal medicine it's like all right we
need a fun one let's go with like a fun